I don't really care about actress
Gwyneth Paltrow but I do care about
scams and I do care about pseudoscience
and Gwyneth Paltrow has been called out
big league for the bogus products that
are being marketed on her website she's
got this lifestyle website called goop
goop com which I guess relates to her
initials and she was under fire a couple
of years ago because her website
recommended something called vagina
steaming where women's squat above
steaming water that includes herbs like
mugwort rosemary wormwood and basil sort
of an alternative health practice and
there's claims about it balancing energy
and balancing hormones you know this
stuff right totally bogus really bad
idea it's bad to heat up parts of your
body that shouldn't be heated up it can
lead to bacterial generation yeast
infections water vapor actually has a
drying impact in many cases so that was
totally insane when it falter was under
fire again because she's selling
wearable healing stickers on her website
these are stickers you can buy on goop
com from a company called body vibes and
they claim that the stickers are made
with the same conductive carbon material
that nASA uses to line spacesuits so
that they can monitor the vitals of
astronauts while they're wearing them
these costs $60 for 10 stickers and they
come quote free program to an ideal
frequency and quote promote healing by
tackling quote imbalances NASA said yeah
we don't use that since they're
mentioned in the marketing NASA put out
a statement saying we don't use carbon
material to line spacesuits it's a total
lie
goop removed the National at NASA
mention and it's just a whole a bogus
pseudoscience thing attached to Gwyneth
Paltrow I hate this stuff yeah I think
I'm going to have to return all of the
merchandise that I bought from Gwen's
Paltrow's website because I feel like
I've been gooped I like that you've been
goups body vibes says it was all a
communications error Jimmy Kimmel
earlier this month asked Gwyneth Paltrow
to walk him through another one of their
healthy living claims check this out
there are a couple of things and I've
written them down here
for instance tell us about earthing what
is earthing okay so one of the things we
like to do on goop is fine kind of what
alternative the alternative world says
about like you know feeling good in the
modern day world the first thing I don't
actually know that much about our thing
and it came out of me not knowing
anything about earthing but hearing
about it it's kind of they say that we
lost touch with sort of being barefoot
in the earth and that there's some type
of electromagnetic thing that we're
missing and notice it's good to take
your shoes off and walk in the grass
right come on just stop selling people
bogus crap is it so hard doesn't she
make enough money from acting she needs
to sell this nonsense that people sell
something useful okay colloidal silver
can be used to align your chakras to
retrograde mercury on the seventh
Tuesday of November so I always do it
stop selling people stuff is this too
much to ask or sell those neon bracelets
I hear they're great for your balance
I've heard about that as well yeah which
have been completely debunked I hate
this crap and I really hate that people
in positions of power are using those
positions to get people to spend money
on garbage all right that's it for today
we've got a great bonus show for you
today david pakman.com slash membership
sign up coupon code
I voted 17 gets you a 40% discount